straight in wind gods versus the dark
prince and it's gonna be heihachi
from wind god what this is gonna be a
win-god battle for sure one for the ages
this is dude this is the final match in
story mode right this is this is this is
kazuya versus hachi this is the one to
rule them all what's going to happen
this didn't work out well for heihachi
by the way spoilers this did not work
but let's see if it does here for the
toc man there we go blow battle let's go
starting it off
right there with the low there oh man
these guys
he has more than just wind i'll tell you
that
but usually when they do three electrics
they do it in combo
he's styling on him right now
he just wanted to show you the point
he's like
hey mom i'm in top eight i'm on stream
what what we're gonna have the electrics
if you're not landing him though that's
the thing
yeah it's all nice he landed three
electrics on the floor you gotta land
him in match let's go
he wants to have an execution battle
with the dark prince i don't know if
that's about to win electric when god
fits halfway across the football field i
could do that oh i got electric train
i have not seen the election trade in a
minute
yeah
nice oh mighty keeps the tail spin
nice dash extra push
the darkest prince oh my god that's
guaranteed
oh the setup
let's set up the dog prince
wow you know what i'm gonna take my
vacation early you got this back
i've seen too much too much pleasure too
much pleasure right now
this is definitely good oh my gosh okay
when god getting something started here
with the otgf
breakfast break on the throw though
electrics win god waking up now
this is what you want to see it goes to
the tech trap doesn't work out for him
though he's back into the wall no punish
oh no
oh he throws up
though that was a mix of oh
how badass is that you get a wall splat
you could have done more damage but no i
wanted to wait for you to he was like
get up
get up i'm gonna help you
that was gangster i love it i love it
my friends brought up now he's like yeah
i wanna fight someone now man yeah i
know i feel it bub crazy stuff yes dark
prince unfortunately didn't get to
punish with the one one two unfortunate
but
um it is what it is man uh dark prince
managed to take that opportunity
you know and uh got the wall splat did
his thing man so what can win god do now
would you switch character probably i
don't i don't know i have control
i don't even know why i mean okay so we
don't know this we only know that he's
picked bob from what we saw on stream
right that's the only thing that we know
was heihachi his main
i don't know that's the thing
we got to figure this out this is like
putting the puzzle pieces together as we
go along
yeah it's i mean uh maybe somebody could
tell us i mean i don't know too much
about him we saw the bob earlier his
name is win god so i'm guessing he was
guessing he was a missionary player
right um but often these things don't
work out that way but either way i mean
execution was looking on point he showed
his electrics and his otgfs and all that
kind of stuff so let's see what he
chooses to do here ladies and lads one o
to the dark prince the last remaining
pakistani
i know what's going on
when you're a mishima player and another
mashima player challenges you you cannot
back down from the challenge you have to
go in if somebody is pumping out the
electricity you have to meet them with
electricity of your own
doing bob is a disservice to your
mashima bloodline
you have to show them the budget that's
that's how you say in our language
you've got to show them the biggerly man
the electricity the the energy you know
what i'm saying here we go yep are we
going to see some pictures from these
guys
oh my gosh he was looking at him
did you see them don't you see the way
he looked at him oh my god that's a bad
omen
that was a great cop
converting oh yo wind guard is in there
spring kick steel pedal oh my god oh my
god
[Music]
this is actually one of my favorite
costumes this is the suzuku kazuya
the biker gang kazuya
i like that that low challenge there
says a lot he knows the options that
have after certain cases
oh he tried to get him i would have i
would have elected
yeah let's go
get the wall
into the street
back too he went for rock come on
interesting
down jump here from dog prince
oh the second hit he's gonna get the
conversion
nice good stuff
oh my gosh he went for the trickery
again the punish
okay
he's getting a lot of mileage maybe he
figured something out round four
yes there you go
when god turning it around dark prince
on the back foot now
slight side step to the adjustment here
nice combo there from dark prince gets
the follow up with the steel pedal
continuing the pressure with hell suits
and stature kicks
spring kicks are working for him
punish they're working for both of them
these guys love spring kings
oh wow oh oh oh oh
god he has rage in this counter he
confirmed he missed the thunder
now what oh he challenged nice here we
go final round this is you dark prince
can either move on in the tournament and
eliminate wind god or wind god's gonna
live to fight another
day when god the last remaining indian
in the tournament
oh the electrics
the dark prince
he's turned on the generator he has the
electrics
this could be he's just standing there
this guy's fighting there the bm
oh oh oh oh oh did they get too scarier
than wave dash just standing there oh my
god
the double low
and the dark prince is gonna take it
over when god eliminating him from the
tournament a good showing fifth place
there